this is a thinker who helps us
understand why our lives and
relationships are full of so much
confusion and pain he tells us why life
is hard and how to cope his own life
incurred a lot of anxieties Sigmund
slomo Freud was born to a middle-class
Jewish family in 1856 his professional
life was not an immediate success as a
medical student he dissected hundreds of
eels in an unsuccessful attempt to
locate their reproductive organs he
promoted cocaine as a medical drug but
it turned out to be a dangerous and
addictive idea a few years later he
founded the discipline that would
ultimately make his name a new
psychological medicine he called
psychoanalysis the landmark study was
his 1900 book the interpretation of
Dreams many others followed despite his
success he was often unhappy during some
particularly strenuous research he
recorded the chief patient I am
preoccupied with is myself he was
convinced he would die between 61 and 62
and had great phobias about those
numbers although he actually died much
later at the age of 83 perhaps because
of his frustrations Freud achieved a
series of deep insights into the sources
of human unhappiness he proposed that we
are all driven by the pleasure principle
which inclines us towards easy physical
and emotional rewards and away from
unpleasant things like drudgery and
discipline as infants we are guided more
or less solely according to the pleasure
principle Freud argued but it will if
adhered to without constraints lead us
to dangerous reckless things like never
doing any work or eating too much or
most notoriously trying to sleep with
members of our own family we need to
adjust to what Freud called the reality
principle though we all have to bow to
this reality principle
Freud believed that they were better or
worse kinds of adaptations he called the
Troublesome ones neuroses neuroses are
the result of faulty negotiations with
or in Freud's language repression of the
pleasure principle Freud described the
conflict between three parts of our
minds the it'd driven by the pleasure
principle
and super-ego driven by a desire to
follow the rules and do the right thing
according to society and the ego which
has to somehow accommodate between the
other two
to understand more about these dynamics
Freud urges to think back to the origins
of our neuroses in childhood as we grow
up we go through what Freud termed the
oral phase where we deal with all the
feelings around ingestion and eating if
our parents aren't careful we might pick
up all kinds of neuroses here we might
take pleasure in refusing food or turn
to food to calm ourselves down or hate
the idea of depending on anyone else for
food then comes the anal phase which is
closely aligned with what we now call
potty training during this period our
parents tell us what to do and when to
go at this phase we begin to learn about
testing the limits of authority again if
things go wrong here if we don't feel
that authority is benign enough we might
for example choose to withhold out of
defiance then as adults we might become
anally retentive in other words not able
to give or to surrender
next comes the phallic phase which goes
on until about the age of six
Freud shocked his contemporaries by
insisting that little children have
sexual feelings moreover in the phallic
phase children direct their sexual
impulses towards their parents the most
immediately available and gratifying
people around Freud famously described
what he called the Oedipus complex where
we are unconsciously predisposed towards
being in love with a one parent and
hating the other what is complex is that
no matter how much our parents love us
they cannot extend this to sexual life
and will always have to have another
life with a partner this makes our young
selves feel dangerously jealous and
angry and also ashamed and guilty about
this anger the complex provides a huge
amount of internalized worry for a small
child ultimately most of us experience
some form of confusion around our
parents that later ties into our ideas
of love mom and dad may both give us
love but they often mix it with
disturbed behavior yet because we love
them we remain loyal to them and also to
their bizarre to struck
patterns for example if our mother is
cold we will be apt nevertheless to long
for her and as a result however we may
be prone to always associate love with a
certain distance naturally the result is
very difficult adult relationships often
the kind of love we've learned from mom
and dad means we can't fuse sex and love
because the people we learnt about love
from are also those we were blocked from
having sex with we might find that the
more in love with someone we are the
harder it becomes to make love to them
this can reach a pitch of crisis after a
few years of marriage and some kids
Freud compared the issues we so often
have with intimacy to hedgehogs in the
winter they need to cuddle for warmth
but they also can't come to close
because they're prickly there's no easy
solution Freud says we can't make
ourselves fully rational and we can't
change society either in his 1930 book
civilization and its discontents Freud
wrote the society provides us with many
things but it does this by imposing
heavy dictates upon us insisting that we
sleep with only a few usually one other
person imposing the incest taboo
requiring us to put off all our
immediate desires demanding that we
follow Authority and work to make money
society themselves are neurotic that is
how they function and that's why there
are constant Wars and other political
troubles Freud attempted to invent a
treatment for are many neuroses he
called it psychoanalysis he thought that
with a little proper analysis people
could uncover what ails them and better
adjust to the difficulties of reality in
his sessions he analyzed a number of key
things he looked at people's dreams
which he saw as expressions of wish
fulfillment he also looked at para
praxis or slips of the tongue we now
call these revealing mistakes Freudian
slips like when we write thigh when we
wanted to write though he also liked to
think about jokes he believed that jokes
often help us make fun of something
symbolic like death or marriage and thus
relieve some of our anxiety about these
topics there's a temptation to say that
Freud just made everything up and life
isn't quite so hard as he makes it out
to be but then one morning we find
ourselves filled with inexplicable anger
towards our partner or running high with
unrelenting anger
on the train to work and were reminded
all over again just how elusive
difficult and Freudian our mental
workings actually are we could still
reject his work of course but as Freud
said no one who disdains the key will
ever be able to unlock the door we could
all use a bit more of Freud's ideas to
help us unpick ourselves
you